what is up do you want to learn some
funny but very useful English let's do
this
[Music]
so I'm Ethan your real-life English
fluency coach and today's lesson will
use a scene from friends that is really
hilarious but it's going to be teaching
you some English that you can use in the
bedroom so if this sounds like something
you're not interested in or that might
be offensive for you then we have a list
of family-friendly lessons that you can
check out up here otherwise first you're
going to watch the scene with subtitles
then we will teach you all the most
important vocabulary pronunciation and
so much more before you test yourself by
watching the final time without
subtitles and I have a special present
for you today it's this PDF power lesson
which is going to help you to study and
deepen your learning with this scene
you're definitely going to want to check
that out you can download it either by
clicking up here or down in the
description below and now it's time to
watch the scene our method for helping
you understand fast speaking natives is
simple first you'll watch the scene with
subtitles then you will learn all the
most important vocabulary expressions
pronunciation cultural context etc and
finally you will test your learning by
watching it a final time without
subtitles our goal is for you to
understand almost a hundred percent
yours
[Music]
like so much can't cut all the ways that
died for you girls and all they can say
is it's not your attack to me okay mmm
weird thing happened to me on the train
this morning
[Music]
all right I panicked all right
see she took me by surprise you know but
it wasn't a total loss I mean we ended
up cuddling whoa how many times i did i
just don't think i'm the dirty-talking
kind of guy you know what's the big deal
you just say what you want to do the
work what you want her to do to you what
you think other people might be doing to
each other try something on me please be
kidding come on just just close your
eyes and tell me what you'd like to be
doing right now okay I'm uh I'm in my
apartment what else
that's it I'm in my apartment you're not
there we're not having this conversation
you get me so hot I want your lips on me
now all right now you say something I
really don't think so
you like this woman right well yeah you
want to see her again right sure but we
can't talk dirty to me how you gonna
talk dirty to her now tell me you want
to caress my butt
okay turn around I just don't want you
staring at me when I'm doing this all
right all right I'm not walking hi
okay hmm
I want okay I want to feel your hot soft
skin with my lips there you go
I want to take my tongue
[Applause]
and say it say it run it all of your
body and trembling
[Music]
[Applause]
we're funny story always ready for you
two kids to get together talk dirty to
talk in a sexual way to someone in order
to make them feel sexually excited say
something
[Music]
Vava the external part of the female
genitalia
the woman ross is with is expecting
something hot or in other words
something with a sexual connotation
vulva doesn't really work for this
because it is a medical or scientific
term and not very sexy all right okay
she she took me by surprise panic to
suddenly feel uncontrollable fear or
anxiety example Greg panicked when she
told him she was pregnant
take someone by surprise to do or say
something unexpected to someone example
the professor's question took me by
surprise and I couldn't come up with an
answer you know but it wasn't a total
loss I mean we ended up cuddling end up
doing something phrasal verb meaning
that you reach a particular place or
achieve a situation after other
activities example after the movie we
ended up going out to dinner after my
trip around Europe I ended up living in
France for a few months cuddle - put
your arms around someone and hold them
close showing affection example she
covered with her baby brother Joey then
asks how many times to make fun of Ross
obviously one might ask this question
about how many times one had sex but not
about cuddling i just don't think i'm
the dirty-talking kind of guy you know
I'm not a dirty talking kind of guy this
is a common way we use to communicate
that we or someone else is or isn't a
certain type of person example he's not
a trend falling kind of guy she's not a
competitive sports kind of gal now it's
your turn
practice your English by giving me a
similar example about yourself down
in the comments I'll go first I'm not a
cheating kind of guy what's the big deal
you just say what you want to do you
just say what you want to do the work or
what you want her to do to you what you
think other people might be doing to
each other who might be doing what you
each other try something on me try
something on me please be kidding I'll
tell you what used to propose a
suggestion or offer example I'll tell
you what if you help me finish this
project I'll buy you dinner to be
kidding to be joking we commonly say I'm
kidding when we want the other person to
know we're not being serious example I'm
just kidding
I didn't lose your cell phone are you
kidding is another common collocation
that we use for asking someone if
they're joking or being serious so if
you're new here I just wanted to take a
moment to tell you to hit that subscribe
button down below and remember to also
hit the bell so that you can be the
first to know about all of our newest
lessons
that's it I'm in my apartment you're not
there we're not having this conversation
okay look this course marker used to get
the other person's attention example
look we can't go too far because I don't
have enough gas in the car to get me so
hot I want your lips on me
I want you it's on me you get me so hot
I want your lips on me now get someone
hot to make someone feel sexually
aroused or feeling like having sex
example his French accent gets her hot
but if you can't talk dirty to me how
are you gonna talk but we can't talk
dirty to me how you gonna talk dirty to
her now tell me you want to caress my
pot caress to touch gently and show
affection example she caressed the
baby's cheek but colloquial non vulgar
word for ass okay turn around I just
don't want you staring at me when I'm
doing this
alright alright I'm not walking I stare
at to look at something or someone
intensely it for a long time example she
stared at the page for several minutes
trying to understand go ahead used to
tell someone to do something especially
if they're waiting for your permission
example can I ask you something sure go
ahead
okay I want to feel your hot soft skin
with my lips there you go there you go
used to say good job or that you're
doing something right
I want to take my tongue and run it all
of your body
shrim the language run something over a
cross along to move something across a
surface example carefully run your
finger along the edge of the knife to
check if it's sharp enough tremble with
something to shake involuntarily example
yours trembling with cold together route
4 to support example I've been rooting
for you to get a job we also use this
word to say which team were wishing to
win example I'll route from Manchester
against Chelsea example I won't be
rooting for the Patriots to win the
Superbowl
alright it's almost time for the test
are you ready but before we jump into
that I wanted to remind you to get your
power lesson PDF so that you can really
master everything that you learned today
and also if you haven't yet and you
enjoyed this lesson be sure to hit that
like button below because it lets
YouTube know that you want more lessons
like this so let's watch the scene again
[Music]
talk to me okay mmm
weird thing happened to be on the train
this morning
[Music]
all right I panicked all right see she
took me by surprise you know but it
wasn't a total loss I mean we ended up
cuddling whoa how many times it was mine
I didn't i just don't think i'm the
dirty-talking kind of guy you know
what's the big deal you just say what
you want to do the work what you want
her to do to you what you think other
people might be doing to each other try
something on me please be kidding come
on just just close your eyes and tell me
what you'd like to be doing right now
[Music]
okay I'm uh I'm in my apartment what
else
that's it I'm in my apartment you're not
there we're not having this conversation
you get me so hot I want your lips on me
now all right now you say something I
don't think so
you like this woman right well yeah you
want to see her again right sure but we
can't talk dirty to me how are you gonna
talk dirty to her now tell me you want
to caress my butt
okay turn around I just don't want you
staring at me when I'm doing this all
right all right
I'm not walking hi okay hmm
I want okay I want to feel your hot soft
skin with my lips there you go I uh I
want to take my tongue
[Applause]
and say it say it run it all of your
body and trembling with
[Music]
[Applause]
we're funny story-- always ready for you
two kids to get together so how did that
test go did you understand a lot more
the second time around I hope that you
have laughed a lot and had a lot of fun
learning with the scene today remember
to download your free power lesson PDF
so that you can master all of this hit
the subscribe button so we can send you
our newest lessons just like this one be
sure to check out this playlist of other
lessons that we have from friends and
finally I have another lesson that I
think you'll really enjoy now go out
there and kick ass with your English uh
yeah